tous vous avez la même attitude les
candidats des autres partis les médias
vous avez le même comportement vous
voulez une élection présidentielle allez
Brou vous ne vous permettez hein vous
permettez vous ne voulez pas oui oui oui
oui vous ne voulez pas du changement ça
fait déjà 40 minutes que nous avons
passé sur les problèmes politiques je
veux maintenant parler de l'économie
alors je vous pose une question
économique vous êtes d'accord non ah bah
alors quelle est la question que nous
pas moi vous m'aurez pas vous savez sur
ce terrain vous voulez pas de question
économique sur sur vous si si moi je
veux commencer par donner l'opinion du
candidat George marché et de son parti
sur les causes de la situation qui a 2
millions de chômeurs d'accord que le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs euh
s'amenuise depuis 1973 si on prend en
compte des revenus les chiffres si plus
vous nous faites perdre de temps moins
je répondrai à vos questions